there's an interesting study that was
done called the Minnesota starvation
experiment it was in 1944 by a man named
Ancel keys the same guy who fudged the
data on the heart study in 1958 which
has led to the false information about
cholesterol causing heart disease that's
the same guy who did this experiment
what Ancel Keys did in the heart study
is he omitted data because he only gave
you the data that aligned with his
premise okay that cholesterol is bad in
a clog the arteries he omitted a lot of
other countries that showed no
relationship between the cholesterol and
heart disease and that's just another
classic example how certain researchers
can manipulate data to look a certain
way
now with this experiment it involved
over 36 men over a course of a year and
the first three months they consumed
3,200 calories okay then after that they
cut the calories down by half to about
fifteen hundred and sixty calories for
six months and this was called a semi
starvation okay now to me that's not
necessarily starvation because you could
live on this if there are nutrient-dense
foods but they wanted to mimic the diet
that was in the war previous to that so
they fed the potatoes rutabagas turnips
bread and macaroni now I see ralph the
bat there's not enough protein there's
definitely not enough essential fatty
acids and there's definitely not enough
vitamins or minerals in this diet over
six months it's going to create some
serious nutritional deficiencies it's
not the starvation of the calories that
I see is the problem it's the starvation
of the nutrients then after the six
months they put them on a restricted
Rehab period and they beefed up the
calories to 2,000 to 3,200 okay where
they fed them more protein more vitamins
and so now they were feeling better and
then after that they put them on an
unrestricted rehab period for short
of time where they pretty much can eat
whatever they want but here's the
outcome they were exhausted irritable
bored cold this would be a thyroid
problem okay because you're starving the
nutrients we've talked about that in
other videos decreased libido craving
food like crazy
they even resorted to stealing food okay
and as the icing on the cake it
destroyed their metabolism kind of
metabolism went way way down and this is
very similar to some of the diets that
are out there that people go on which
are low-calorie diets when you're on a
healthy keto plan and you're doing in a
minute fasting your energy goes up okay
especially if you're doing healthy keto
you're not going to be irritable your
your moods gonna come way up and you're
probably gonna find that your libido
goes up you're not gonna crave food your
hunger goes away you're probably not
going to end up stealing food because
you're not hungry
and your metabolism is going to be fine
so that is the benefit and the unique
distinction between healthy keto and
fasting versus a semi-starvation
typical low calorie diet that a lot of
people actually go on which they don't
really pay attention to the quality of
food so I put a link down below for the
actual study but I want to just point
this out because many people that do
fasting do not do healthy keto okay and
they end up with problems and it's
totally unnecessary so what we can learn
from this is the importance of
nutrient-dense foods and all of the side
effects that we can prevent and also if
we're trying to do this with weight loss
the last thing we want to do is destroy
the metabolism thanks for watching so if
you want more knowledge on how to create
a healthy body subscribe now and get
daily notifications